et bien bonjour à tous et à toutes
alors je sais bien que je me suis auto
abonné aux dossiers un peu compliqué
mais parler après sa sainteté le pape
françois et jean loup chrétien et avant
marek halter d'un petit peu compliqué
bon le sexe et la politique est sans
doute le sujet que j'aurais dû choisir
pour m'assurer de votre attention tenue
est constante mais ça n'est pas ce que
j'ai fait je vais vous parler de
démocratie quelques instants dans le
format ted
on est à une période qui est une période
tout à fait charnière une époque
absolument passionnante passionnante
parce qu' 'il vient de se passer il y à
quelques semaines quelque chose que
personne n'avait pu ou su pronostiqué
c'est à dire une équipe celle du nouveau
président de la république arrivants et
dynamitant les parties tout à la fois
les parties et le monde politique
tel qu'on le connaissait pour le jeter
dans un précipice duquel ce monde
sortira nécessairement améliorer par
rapport à ce qu'il était puisque nous
avions tous ce goût et je crois ne pas
vous engager au delà de ce que vous
auriez souhaité en le disant mais de
républicains peu finissant tout le
système un peu terminant comme ça donc
tous les pronostics on se sont avérés
faux tous les pronostiqueurs ont échoué
mais on sait par ailleurs que les
pronostics c'est pour les rêveurs et
pour les turfistes et donc ici il ya
peut-être des rêveurs mais sans doute un
peu moins de d'amateurs d'hippodromes et
on se retrouve dans une configuration
assez simple où dans cette période
charnière
je crois qu'on a le devoir de
s'interroger sur ce qu'est notre
démocratie sur ce qu'elle est devenue et
sur ce que nous allons en faire et je
vous propose un petit voyage au travers
d'un certain nombre de grands principes
qui régissent la république française
alors je sais bien et vous l'aurez
constaté avant que je vous le dise que
les grands principes en général
recueil acquis trop de conséquence des
tout-petits développement il ya une
raison à ça c'est que je crois que
confusément nos contemporains nos
concitoyens les français que nous sommes
savent que les grands principes ne sont
pas ou ne sont pas tout le temps
appliquer ce qui pose une difficulté en
matière démocratique naturellement alors
si on part de l'origine de ce qui nous
unit en tant que pays et en tant que
peuple on se retrouve face à l'article
premier de la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen du 26 août 1789
avec un article premier qui est tout à
fait clair et qui est absolument
fascinant
les hommes naissent et demeurent libres
et égaux en droits donc cet agrégat de
quelques mots mis bout-à-bout signifie
que le fait de naître pour chacun de
nous nous offre à titre de conséquence
le droit de demeurer libre et d'être les
en égaux des autres ce principe à valeur
constitutionnelle nous y reviendrons est
un principe qui est intangible c'est un
principe qui est indépassable cet
endroit c'est quelque chose qui nous est
dû en tant que citoyen l'article 2
poursuit là le but de toute association
politique est la conservation des droits
naturels et imprescriptibles de l'homme
et ces droits sont la liberté la
propriété la sûreté et on y reviendra
la résistance à l'oppression et ce ne
sont pas que des mots la résistance à
l'oppression c'est à dire que cela va
impliquer pour chacun d'entre nous
individuellement et à titre de
communauté nationale de savoir si nous
subissons une oppression ou pas et dans
le cas où nous la subirions nos aînés
nos glorieuses aînées ont laissé dans un
article 35 d'un projet de constitution
de juin 1793 un article sur lequel je
reviendrai plus tard qui nous donne une
voix et
sorte de cap à suivre en ce cas là donc
voilà pour ce qui est de ses textes
la constitution du 4 octobre 1958 donc
5ème république nous dit maintenant le
peuple français en son préambule
proclame solennellement son attachement
aux droits de l'homme et aux principes
de la souveraineté nationale tels qu'ils
ont été définis par la constitution 1789
et de poursuivre en article 1er la
france est une république une république
indivisible laïque démocratique
elle assure l'égalité devant la loi de
tous les citoyens sans distinction
d'origine vous le savez de race ou de
religion donc l'égalité devant la loi
cet article l'article 1er est une
disposition constitutionnelle de
laquelle il nous est possible de tirer
une conséquence qui est primordial pour
chacun d'entre nous sait que la loi
telle qu'elle est telle qu'elle existe
doit être appliquée à tous de la même
manière c'est à dire qu'elle ne doit pas
mettre appliquer plus durement parce que
j'ai agacer ou plus souplement parce que
j'aurai un passe droit que je serai le
fils de tel ou tel ou l'oncle de tel
autre donc application de la loi à tous
c'est un pilier démocratique
l'article 6 maintenant et on en a
bientôt terminé avec les articles mais
je pense qu'il est important de regarder
quels sont les fondements juridiques et
constitutionnelles de ce qui fait de
notre pays une démocratie l'article 6 de
la déclaration de l'homme et des
citoyens nous dit la loi est
l'expression de la volonté générale tous
les citoyens ont le droit de concourir
personnellement ou par leurs
représentants à sa formation et
d'ajouter elle doit être la même pour
tous soit qu'elle protège soit qu'elle
punisse
dans ce contexte là il est possible
d'affirmer et à vous dire la vérité je
crois même qu'il est impossible
d'affirmer l inverse il est possible
d'affirmer disait que nous ne sommes pas
en démocratie si la loi n'est pas
appliquée à tous de la même manière
on vous a invité à voter certains
d'entre vous l'ont fait et à cette
invitation il était possible de répondre
je vote pour l'en je vote pour l'autre
je ne vote pas car je ne suis pas
inscrit sur les listes
je ne vote pas en étant inscrit sur la
liste je suis donc un abstentionniste je
vote blanc où je vote nul je ne pense
pas avoir oublié quelques hypothèses que
ce soit il se trouvait beaucoup d'entre
vous l'ont d'ores et déjà compris que
seuls ceux qui ont voté pour l'un ou
pour l'autre se sont exprimés puisque
les autres ne sont pas comptabilisés
cela pose déjà ici une difficulté
démocratique puisque il s'agissait
d'élire nos dirigeants nous l'avons fait
parce que la france le fait toujours
elle n'est pas la belgique elle et la
france donc nous avons un gouvernement
la belgique a été son gouvernement
quelques temps et ceux de nos amis
anarchiste qui nous regarderons se
diront immédiatement que aucun belge
n'est mort de ça et que le pays a
continué à fonctionner particulièrement
bien bon
dans ce contexte là la question qui se
pose c'est celle de la représentativité
de nos gouvernants être vous
représentatif lorsque vous avez été élu
quand vous calculez tout ça avec 15 à
20% des expressions de ceux qui étaient
en âge et en droit de voter
de mon point de vue non mais la
représentativité d'un président de la
république et de son gouvernement n'est
que le reflet le reflet de la confiance
que nous citoyens nous témoignons à ce
gouvernement
il y a aujourd'hui une crise de
représentativité que je n'invente pas
dont vous avez lu les stigmates dont
tous les journaux français politique qui
existe et il m'apparaît comme il
apparaît à d'autres que cette crise de
représentativité provient de ce que nous
ne sommes pas dans un système de
politique contractuelle un système de
prod politique contractuelle
engendrerait le fait que me présentant à
vous et vous disant je me présente aux
fins de remplir tel programme
le fait de me être engagée par
définition crée des obligations pour moi
à votre endroit
or en l'espèce on le voit et vous le
savez vous le savez très précisément
rien n'empêche un politique de ne pas
respecter son programme
vous seriez d'ailleurs choqué si un
politique se mettaient à respecter son
programme
mais ce schéma de politique
contractuelle est quelque chose sur
lequel sur la foi des textes légaux et
et des textes constitutionnels surtout
sur la foi de projets sur la foi duquel
nous devrions réfléchir ensemble en tant
que citoyen parce que tout le reste de
la vie est basée sur un contrat
les relations commerciales sont basés
sur un contrat les relations amoureuses
c'est triste à dire mais sont basés sur
un contrat il n'y a guère que la
politique qui ne soit pas basée sur un
contrat
il est possible je crois de dire sans
aller trop loin et en tout cas pas au
delà de ce que je souhaite aujourd'hui
que la politique est plus fondées sur
des concepts de marketing que sur des
concepts contractuels qui ferait que
m'engageant à votre endroit je crée une
obligation dont je suis le débiteur et
dont vous êtes le créancier donc cette
piste de contractualisation est une
piste qui me semble être
particulièrement intéressante non
seulement pour l'avocat que je suis mais
également et surtout pour le citoyen que
je suis de recherche il y à une problème
une problématique sur l'application de
la loi qui
me rend particulièrement nerveux et ça
sera peut-être le cas pour certains
d'entre vous et nerveux au point d'en
perdre le sommeil depuis quelques temps
quelques temps ça veut dire depuis mon
adolescence
alors je sais bien que ce n'est pas un
tadic sur le sommeil mais l'idée était
quand même de réfléchir ensemble à des
solutions qui nous permettraient de
d'aller au delà on l'a vu de sondages en
début de semaine et est fière 75% nos
compatriotes considèrent que nos élites
sont corrompus par khalid il faut
entendre élite du gouvernement et 66,1 %
je crois que le 1% est important et
surtout que les statistiques sont
toujours fausse à 88% des 66 1 % de nos
compatriotes considèrent que la
moralisation de la voie de la vie
publique et politique est une priorité
nationale
la question que nous devons nous poser
en tant que citoyen et peuple français
est celle de savoir si nos dirigeants
vont entendre cela ou continuer à nous
amener vers le précipice alors je sais
bien que tenir ce propos dans un état de
grâce est presque une insulte mais force
est de constater que nous vivons
aujourd'hui en tant que français dans
une année blanche
je m'explique sur ce concept d'année
blanche depuis septembre 2016 on vous a
parlé des primaires de la gauche puis
ensuite des primaires de la droite puis
de ce qui allait partir hors primaire
puis du champion de la gauche
enfin du champion de la droite puis
encore du débat entre les champions puis
des deux finalistes puis de celui qui a
gagné de la nomination de son premier
ministre de la formation de son
gouvernement de l'état de grâce je suis
en train de fouler aux pieds de saccager
comme le petit malotru que je suis
puisse ensuite la trêve estivale
et puis il y aura la rentrée politique
de l'année d'après que s'est-il passé
pendant la durée de cette année je veux
dire en dehors de ces agitations
politiques et bien strictement rien
c'est là toute la magie de la politique
vous pouvez considérer que personne
n'est mort en france 2 fin personne
n'est mort de froid
personne n'est mort des conséquences de
la précarité ni en france ni ailleurs
rien n'a été avant
on était de suffisamment sensible qu'il
faille en faire quelques lignes dans des
journaux télévisés puisque seuls cette
politique a compté le malheur pour nous
est que cette politique je vous le
disais n'est pas contractuelles et que
si elle l'était on serait dans indret
jeu là en l'occurrence ça n'est pas le
cas il y a en france un système
judiciaire puisque vous l'avez compris à
la halle à la lecture de ces de ses
articles de la constitution française la
justice et l'indépendance plus
exactement l'indépendance de la justice
est le pilier fondamental d'une
démocratie et il y a en france un
appareil judiciaire qui fonctionne
particulièrement bien pour un dossier
vous madame contre vous monsieur parce
qu'aucun d'entre vous n'est un riche
industriel aucun d'entre vous n'êtes un
banquier de premier plan
aucun d'entre vous n'êtes un candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
et vous n'êtes pas non plus les cousins
de ce que je viens de citer donc le juge
fera très bien son travail vous n'êtes
pas dans un dossier signalé mais quand
on est dans un dossier signalé type la
sphère dit kerviel contre société
générale et bien la justice se met à dix
fonctionnaires prenons des instructions
n'appliquant plus l'égalité de tous les
citoyens devant la loi
nous éloignons en définitive de cette
étape démocratique qui est l'état
théorique de notre pays est si vous
prenez même le mot ne serait ce que le
mot démocratie démocratie sa définition
est assez simple c'est un système
politique donc on verra pour la
conclusion que le mot système n'est pas
un gros mot système politique forme de
gouvernement dans lequel la souveraineté
émane du peuple le peuple c'est vous
c'est nous et quant à l'étymologie du
mot démocratie
il vient du grec dêmos le peuple kratos
le pouvoir je sais pas si on peut dire
le pouvoir au peuple
ça c'est peut-être un idéal que mais en
tout cas on le voit notre système nous a
car trop éloigné de ses concepts qui le
fonde qui sont des concepts de base est
la vraie révolution consisterait
aujourd'hui à appliquer la loi telle
qu'elle est telle qu'elle va est telle
qu'elle devient puisque la loi est en
perpétuelle évolution mais l'appliquer à
tous par l'appliquer à quelques va nu
pieds qui ne pèse rien pour en exonérer
les autres l'appliquer à tous de la même
manière c'est à dire que bon je sais ça
va faire un peu de casse quelques
ministres vont faire des heures de garde
à vue
c'est pas la coutume ils feront de la
détention provisoire ce n'est pas la
coutume mais c'est pourtant ce que
subissent nos compatriotes je veux dire
quand ils ne respectent pas la loi
hélas cette révolution consisterait dans
le fait d'appliquer la loi à tous d'une
manière absolument tu équitable de même
que je crois profondément que nous nous
devons en tant que peuple français de
nous doter d'un fichier citoyens fichier
national citoyen de nos élus condamnés
pour faire le travail qui est le mien
par exemple c'est à dire être avocat à
la cour
je n'ai pas le droit d'avoir un casier
judiciaire vous le savez mais tout comme
pour beaucoup d'autres boulots mais en
revanche étant condamnés on a le droit
de se présenter à la présidence de la
république française
parce que ça serait moins important que
d'être avocat ou que de passer le bafa
ou que de travailler avec des enfants
alors on le voit aujourd'hui tout ça est
un peu 2007 2008 2009 2010 c'est démodé
notre attention doit être portée en tant
que peuple français sur l'application de
la loi telle qu'elle a été écrite et de
la constitution telle qu'elle a été
conçue par nos aînés et en parlant de
nos aînés jeu
vous livre dans quelques instants un
texte qui n'a jamais été appliquée mais
qui nous donne une idée de la manière
dont nous pourrions travailler ensemble
à sept as et un système démocratique a
cru la difficulté pour les gens comme
moi que l'on appelle des contestataires
c'est qu'ils ont du mal à travailler
ensemble parce que les contestataires
ont toujours attendu d'être d'accord sur
tout pour aller dans le même sens or les
contestataires conteste ils ne sont
d'accord sur rien alors je me suis
efforcé dans l' ouvrage dont il a été
question et que j'ai écrits lors de la
présentation de renverser cette équation
et en me disant n'attendons pas d'être
d'accord sur tout pour travailler
ensemble mais unissons nous autour de
nos contestations compatible nos
contestations compatible c'est à dire
que je pourrais quand à moi travailler
avec quelqu'un d'extrême droite parce
qu'il a compris que la prééminence de la
finance sur la justice est intolérable
et ça ce serait une vraie victoire de ce
schéma jeudi avec quelqu'un
d'extrêmement parce que je ne suis pas
d'extrême droite donc je veux illustrer
au plus serré le fait que nous pouvons
travailler autour de nos contestations
compatibles et je crois que de façon
bienveillante
il est possible de marquer nos
politiques et de faire en sorte qu'ils
respectent la loi parce que c'est ce que
nous attendons d'eux pour une plus
grande représentativité enfin et en
conclusion ces quelques lignes qui sont
d'importance parce que
nos pères fondateurs l'ont voulue comme
sa constitution de 24 juin 93 articles
35 quand le gouvernement viole les
droits du peuple l'insurrection est pour
le peuple et pour chaque portion du
peuple le plus sacré des droits et le
plus indispensable des devoirs le plus
sacré des droits et le plus
indispensable des devoirs
ça c'est ce que nous serons contraints
de faire si le reste ne fonctionne pas
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]